I called Robin up and I said you know
this year for your birthday what I want
to do is have a birthday dinner for you
so invite ten people do you mind me
talking about this but it's gonna insult
some people um well think about it some
people weren't invited
yeah so you did a really great thing he
goes the following list Gary and Mary
Dell'Abate I went oh good somebody for
me to charge yeah right Fred and Alison
Norris and John and John's wife what
Debbie Debbie him with the hi I got to
admit I understood the Fred and Alison
in the Gary and Mary I was shocked by
the Jon Hein and Debbie really yeah I
didn't know that you are funny when I
mentioned them no we do what I say
you said so you do like John huh yeah I
mean I didn't know that you really the
John Heim one caught me and I was like
I'd listen I loved John but then I
realized why were John George John
sounds like a baby yeah and I could tell
he was bummed out because the menu
didn't have like a hamburger or a french
fry impressed with that food come on
John did you open your mind up last
night and enjoy the food because he had
never been to a John George before a
restaurant with this is the first
restaurant he went to that didn't have
plastic straws were you impressed I mean
did you open your mind up because the
food there is I've never had a bad meal
there ever was very good yeah it's not
my typical meal to say the least but did
it open you up to the idea of some fine
dining ah no no oh gee well first of all
I saw he was ordering all the wrong
things like what do you order i when you
told me we were going there I
immediately went to the menu to study
because I wanted to be prepared but
there are different ways they can I
wasn't sure if we were gonna be able to
pick what we were going to eat or no of
course I even nuns Robin I said let's go
with because God knows what John wants
so I was thankful for
that and then on the only John he knows
his Papa John George
so the first course had like a choice of
all this caviar stuff we I've never had
so I skip that go ahead so I there was a
salad option and everyone here thinks
for some reason that I don't eat
vegetables but I do I eat salads all the
time Gary doesn't eat that so you
ordered like the most boring entree
ordered a salad and then the second
course was I got a mixed vegetables
steamed expensive that's when I looked
at what he got like I wouldn't even get
mixed vegetables there you don't you
don't get that at John George it should
have had what I had you should had the
pea soup with those cheese puffs I
didn't please see this [ __ ] guy he
didn't it was a hefty bill I was going
to say someone you invited him because
you know what it is thinking of how I
wanted to spend the time yeah I enjoyed
the company I appreciated the invite I
think the restaurant is fantastic but
for me I was just trying not to
embarrass myself because they would
serve stuff in between when the food
came out and I had no idea what that was
like that little corn showed up and I
was like did you try it yeah I did I ate
everything would you jab your main dish
I had Parmesan chicken which was very
good I felt for John cuz I think he was
very confused by everything and I think
we realize it was this bad you know and
in fact at one point they brought this
is the best they brought this little
gelatin ball to like cleanse your palate
yeah dinner and it was very delicate so
we all put it in and put it on about the
broken jaw when John picked it up and he
squeezed it I was thinking a Herman
Munster whatever you used to like pick
stuff up but you are right Howard there
are already some hard feelings of people
I knew it when you first started talking
about it
Jason stopped by the office and he goes
well who's invited this dinner and I go
well Fred and I point I just pointed to
John with my finger and he just goes ooh
he's okay he's okay does Jason think he
that Robin should have chosen him over
John hind we are people wondering why
John hunt Howard yeah I'm not upset that
I wasn't invited when I found out Johnny
my reaction was like I didn't even know
John and Robin knew each other let alone
we'll go to dinner with each other yeah
and I said to Rob thank you cuz I can't
afford Jason and John hainan the same
Bill those are two big boys when Ralph
wakes up he's gonna be pissed yeah now
see that I could understand people being
pissed about Israel had been invited and
by the way John were you shocked when
you got the invite yes I was surprised I
was surprised when I think I'm being
pleasantly surprised look Rob and I are
closer than I guess everybody here
realizes right but you're always saying
we were talking about it this morning
John was saying that it's almost
embarrassing because they bring out
everybody's dinner and they explain what
everybody's having yeah and just like
well what if I don't want people to know
what a McDonald yes so Ronnie's
downstairs waiting for our guest but I
texted him and asked if he was upset he
wasn't invited he wrote and I don't know
if he's serious or joking he's wrote I
am I guess I'm on the bottom of that
chain not enough class for them lol for
them and you know what you want to know
something I had a feeling Ronnie would
be upset anyone what the [ __ ] is wrong
with him I mean Robin likes Ronnie
I love Ronnie but not enough to go to
add attendees not on the top of that
list oh I knew Ronnie would be Bob yeah
who was number 11 debate like I only had
10 I didn't had there was again the
thought of Ralph did come up but I said
no hmm thank you I mean probably on the
cut if Ralph was there I would have been
happy weren't we really only 9:00 last
night yes yes yes we were so there was
room for attempt there was but Bobby
this is who Robin wanted yeah is Benji
upset I bet he be I think he thinks he
should be in on that probably and it had
nothing to do with what our
relationships are in the office right it
was their relationships out of the
office right Howard the best part was
the dessert
yes they brought out you know a piece of
chocolate cake for Robin and we sang we
tried to sing happy birthday and then
the chocolate cake immediately got over
to Gary Gary was in heaven
he had the shrimp with bacon early on
and then there was so much chocolate on
that table oh my just like my chocolate
too I had white chocolate I gave it to
him you wouldn't believe that was me
holding back yeah I don't want to hear
from Benji it's hard to articulate he
goes I'm not upset that I wasn't invited
but with John and I go what would turn
he goes I don't know how to say that go
are you mad that you're not in front of
John he goes not exactly but kind of hmm
John seems to be pissing everybody off
well anyway it was fun night yeah thank
Robin GI dgb Thank You Robin I think
that you both cuz you pay right right
but I really had no idea that John Hine
was this kind of lightning rod
that's me yeah Jim from North Carolina
go ahead hey Robin happy birthday
anymore thank you
Ronnie should be upset with you but not
getting invited to your party
why look I could only invite ten people
I gave her a limit I said ten the thing
that blew everyone's mind that John hime
I don't know why they just didn't know
you had that level of friendship
relationship people are interested in
and what happens between you and Ronnie
Ronnie I think Robin realized Ronnie's
nuts no Ronnie are you upset that Robin
seriously I mean I want to know the
truth don't give me [ __ ] no I don't
care anymore
anymore because you know what I know my
place on the chain I know where I'm at I
said to Robin invite ten people I'm
throwing you a birthday party at John
George it put the crying music idea put
it away you know in a way it gives her
nettle going back when who our real
friends were you know back in the day
you were a lot closer to her than John
he never was oh [ __ ] yeah Ronnie's kind
of put this on me really why I heard
that you thought that John got invited
cuz it was my idea Oh
just made that as a joke saying that
good what many a truth is said in jest
what I said was Jesus Christ me can't
say [ __ ] around well all I said was
maybe gary said that John's a good
conversation person to bring to dinner
like he's a good call from Rob I didn't
talk to Gary about all right Gary calm
down gee you're the only one yelling
dude crying I told him I know my place
here John Hine is not an electrifying
conversationalist he barely said a word
is plenty to say I think I was talking
just as much as everybody else at the
dinner were you yeah I talk a lot to
Ojai right you wouldn't know because you
didn't invite me Robin that's okay I
told you were you Ronnie covered with
Ronnie puppy you're clearly hurt did you
sit home staring at the wall talking to
him or pretending you were at the party
you know the other thing is that Howard
invited me out to dinner right okay so
what does that mean means you should
have invited her to there that's what
she's saying oh okay is that what you're
saying Robin and everybody at that table
has invited me out yeah yeah we'll do
that
[ __ ] you see that's why I know what
do you know now the truth comes out
[ __ ]
now you know yeah because you know many
times I've said to her we should get
together oh yeah we're gonna get
together where did John Huynh invite you
Robin he's invited me out to dinner yes
yeah yes off wait I know that Ronnie but
it's never an official invitation it's
like we should get together about we
should get together we gather yeah you
should get together with Ronnie's we can
yell sixty-nine
I go out I yell I sit in the middle of
restaurant I don't know what you do give
me a [ __ ] chair Robin I'll give you a
Sophie's Choice you have to have dinner
with one not good see the Ronnie or John
hein who do you go with I would choose
Ronnie now because I have dinner without
John now you would go I'm gonna stay
home and wax my NASCAR tire [ __ ] you I
don't want to go anywhere